au Petit Palais théâtre maintenant après
avoir tâé du Tour de champ et du cinéma
Les Charlots ont décidé de monter sur
les planches ils ont trouvé une pièce
qui compte trois personnages égau la
seule sans doute dans le répertoire elle
s'appelle la cuisine des anges et elle
est signé Alber Russon 6 mois de tournée
en province pour les Charlots avant
d'affronter Paris auparavant je vous
rappelle que notre dernier journal vous
sera présenté à 23h10 par gerérard hols
bonne soirée donc en commençant par
cette cuisine des
anges pour la première fois de carrière
les Charlots ne saluent pas seuls avec
la troupe des tourné Barret il débutent
au théâtre dans la cuisine des anges qui
e pour interprète hfy Bogart et Peter
hustinov 1hure du matin ils font une
ville par jour le problème est de
trouver des rela gastronomiques qui
soient ouverts la
nuit 7h de quart h on arrive et Gérard
me dit surtout jeano ne mange pas avant
d'entrer en scène parce qu'après tu es
lourd il faut pas rentrer en scène avec
le ventre trop lourd alors je mange
après après c'est toujours fermé c'est
rare qu'on trouve quelque chose alors on
mange un petit peu après alors comme je
sais qu'on mange un petit peu après je
mange un petit peu avant maintenant et
je mange un petit peu le matin je mange
un petit peu l'après-midi je mange un
petit peu tout le temps je mange
jamais la couverture bataille chaque
jour 3h de quart avec toute la troupe et
cela depuis un mois et demi encore 5
mois à faire et puis la création à Paris
mais est-ce que leur enthousiasme ne
sera pas un peu émoussé au bout de de
ça oui je crois parce que d'AB c'est la
première
fois on joue à ça ENF il a à parisin il
y a beaucoup de de choses nouvelles
qu'on apprend qu'on qu'on apprécie parce
que c'est tout neuf et je crois qu'on
sera pas lassé même après de de saisons
entières de la
cuisine ma parole s évanouie évidemment
elle fait pas la sieste
on peut pas la laisser comme ça personne
ne vient qu'est-ce qu'on fait bougez pas
les enfants moi je me déoue mais
qu'est-ce que tu veux faire un petit
massage cardiaque suivi d'un petit
bouche à bouche je te suis alors et
attention c'était peut-être une lettre
empoisonn ça je faisait beaucoup du
temps desbord attends attends attends je
vais t'aider c'est pas la peine c'est
très délicat le genre d'opération
laisse-moi justement faut se rlayer le
temps je t'assure que non ah je t' vous
avez trouvé une pièce où il y avait
trois rôles par chance comment est-ce
que vous vous lesz être
réparti qui nous les a répartis les
personnages de la pièce ressemblait à
peu près à ce qu'on est je veux dire euh
moi Joseph ouais je suis pas un assassin
moi x deux c'est des assassins dans
cette pièce c'est choses qui sont dans
la vie est-ce qu' vous arrive de vous
disputer entre vous tout le temps surout
au
car vous étiez là vous étiez
là un petit
bisou les Barb est barbus est Barb
il y a le le public habituel du théâtre
qui vient parce que parce c'est celui
qui est habituel justement on draine un
petit peu de de la clientèle Charlot
qu'on a eu grâce au cinéma grâce à la
chanson et je crois que ça fait tout ça
tout ça ça fait un espèce de public un
peu un peu étrange nouveau au
théâtre mais qui est très bon pour nous
que les gens qui sont des habités du thâ
il il met P ils sont un peu surpris
parce qu'ils s'attendent pas à ce que
venant des
Charlot à autre chose que ce spectacle
là non mais vous jouez quand même pas du
corneile c'est pas corne qu'on a
rencontré à Ly qu'est-ce que tu m'as
raconté
toi
douon avantage des tourné on apprend la
géographie et le
folklore
Toto mange ta soupe a
beaucoupère cuill et on fait des
rencontres enrichissantes mais qu'en
pensent les charlottes de ces voyages
dans
épou
nous mais pourquoi vous nous accomp vous
accompagneriez pas jusqu'à la V vous
fait elles viennent de temps en temps
dans la mesure du possible elles aiment
elles aiment pas mal hein bon la pièce
commence à connaître par pour nous
remplacer même à la
limite B
[Musique]
ch et
trè
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
he